a source tells et that justin and haley
bieber believe a big family is in their
destiny
[Music]
hopefully
we squish out a nugget our source says
the 27 year old singer and 25 year old
model have been in a great place
they're closer than ever and have a
really healthy balanced and supportive
relationship adding they want to have a
big family someday they both know what
great parents they're going to be
together they both feel like part of
their reason for being on earth was to
be parents it has been instilled in them
since day one and they're looking
forward to making that happen i bet you
when i have kids i'm gonna be like i
didn't even know what patience was
before that earlier this month haley got
candid about when she plans to have kids
with her husband as she graced the cover
of wsj magazine's spring women's fashion
issue haley tells the mag in part quote
everybody always assumes it's first
comes love then comes marriage then
comes the baby well what about all the
things i want to accomplish in my
business
she also says initially it was ingrained
in her mind to have kids immediately
after getting married but she had a
change of heart
so when does the couple think they'll be
ready haley says i think ideally in the
next couple of years we would try but
there's a reason they call it try right
you don't know how long that process is
ever going to take definitely no kids
this year that would be a little hectic
i think as for justin's perspective on
the whole kids subject here's what he
shared in his documentary last year
justin bieber our world hopefully we
squish out a nugget uh in 2021
the end of 2021 we we start trying okay
maybe
we shall see
it's a few babes and back in 2020 the
ghost singer revealed to ellen degeneres
how many kids he wants
uh i think it's up to haley because it's
her body good answer justin
[Music]
you